this course is from treehouse instructor
and senior product designer
hope armstrong you'll learn all you need
to know about creating good typography
which is one of the most important
aspects of good design
hey i'm hope armstrong a teacher and
product designer here at treehouse
every day you see typography in action
it's on the menu of that restaurant
you love eating at it's on road signs
you drive by
and it's definitely all over that
favorite site of yours which is
let's be honest tree house of course
all that to say typography is everywhere
whether people realize it or not
something so ubiquitous is often taken
for granted
but it's really powerful as designs are
often
mostly comprised of type there's so much
to learn
first we need to understand what
typography is
on matthew butterick's site practical
typography
he defines the term simply as follows
typography is the visual component of
the written word
this means typography comes into play
when words are visually displayed on
surfaces
like screens paper posters signs and
more
though the words or content of something
might remain the same
the typography can change let's take a
look
here's the text i shot the serif we can
shape how it looks through typography
for example we could increase the size
of the text and align it in the center
we could change the typeface from
georgia to futura
and set it in uppercase letters we could
also adjust the letter spacing
or tracking between characters we could
go on forever
making different adjustments but i
wanted to give you a quick sample of
typography
and action if you don't know how to do
any of these things
don't worry we'll cover how to
practically apply
all of this and more later on in the
course
so far we've seen that typography
involves changing
arranging or ordering type but we
wouldn't want to do this without a
purpose or reason as to why
a major purpose behind typography is
utility
this means presenting the text in a way
that is useful
clear and legible to its reader the
content of a webpage could be incredible
but if the typography is lackluster then
it's going to be
difficult for people to read and
navigate
they'll either struggle through it or
quit along the way
both situations are undesirable this
is why typography as utility is
extremely important
to present text in a way that's clear
orderly and legible
for readers and users of your site
another purpose behind typography
is designing for an emotional connection
type can have a personality or mood
it gives off a certain vibe and conveys
something to the reader
before they've even digested a single
word on the page
the flavor of your typography should
match the voice of your content
you wouldn't want something that looks
like chocolate ice cream
to taste like tater tots
let's say you have an official serious
business document
that's set in a fun quirky typeface
although the content might send the
right message the design
or typography would not at all as you
practice typography
you'll want to make sure the design
aspect of it enhances the message at
hand
it can keep readers engaged and also
create delight in them
because so many different things can
come into play
good typography might seem a bit tricky
at first to execute
i like to think of it as striking a
balance between utility
and designing for an emotional
connection
throughout this course we'll look at
different ways to maintain that balance
because typography is one of the most
important elements
of design next i want to make a
distinction between typography
and lettering these are two fields that
are popular today
but commonly confused in the industry
both
deal with letter forms but in different
ways
typography involves working with
pre-made letter systems
like typefaces and fonts to layout and
arrange content
whereas lettering involves crafting
letterforms for a single use and purpose
instead of utilizing a pre-made letter
system
this definition is based on joseph
alicio's article and the teacher's notes
it's great for further reading now that
we understand the difference
our focus for this course will be on
typography
and you'll be able to use those terms
correctly in your industry
lastly let's look at what a typeface is
and the elements that define and shape
it
the terms typeface and font are commonly
used interchangeably today
but they are distinctly different a
typeface is the design of a collection
of characters
so the term should be used when talking
about the look of those
letters numbers and symbols for example
i dig futura it's such a good looking
typeface
a font is a single instance or
embodiment of a specific
weight width or style of a typeface
for example the computer file for
helvetica bold italic would be a font
whereas helvetica would be the typeface
next time you're out and about spot some
typography you like
and take note of what distinguishes it
and how it makes you feel in the next
video
i'll explain how typography relates to
the user experience
typography makes or breaks a design when
done well it elicits emotions and
conjures an understanding or connection
to a brand
equally just as successfully it can slip
away unnoticed
as it makes reading so easy and
pleasurable that the reader doesn't
fixate on the letter forms themselves
the typography communicates without
getting in the way
poor typography gives people a lower
impression of a brand
product or service and even worse it can
make an experience
difficult or confusing i'll cover three
main ways that typography affects the
user experience
first typography is a major component of
branding
look at any product you use and observe
the typography
the company has chosen a typeface that
aligns with the brand message
it also aligns and differentiates itself
from other brands
typefaces conjure various connotations
that are influenced by culture and
cognitive biases
and they affect how we feel about the
brands
second readability is important the
shape of letters
space between letters space between
lines
and width of lines all affect a person's
ability to easily read text
it's so common for us busy humans to
quickly scan text
instead of reading every word so
improving the scan ability of text is
something ux designers seek out
third let's touch on accessibility
accessibility is a core component of
product design
because it means to make a product or
service easy to use
designing for accessibility benefits
everyone
not just those who are differently abled
remember that the people who use a
product you're designing
may have a physical cognitive language
or learning disability
they may have color blindness low vision
or use a screen reader to navigate the
web
as far as the design goes if you adhere
to the best practices of typography
your design will naturally be set up to
be quite accessible
choosing a typeface with distinctive
easy to read letters
and appropriate contrast then correctly
applying
heading levels creating clear visual
hierarchy
maintaining proper alignment and making
the text adequately sized will benefit
everyone here are a few specific tips
people with visual impairments use
screen readers which read the text on
the screen
therefore for non-text-based media such
as videos
it's advisable to add a way to see the
captions or transcripts
the same is true for photos which should
contain either visual captions or a
description
implemented with code don't bake text
into images
add text to websites and apps using
markdown such as html
so it's accessible to screen readers
also text added and markdown can be
enlarged
whereas raster images get pixelated when
enlarged
if you must include text and images add
the text to the image element with an
alt tag when it gets
implemented in code when conveying info
such as state changes and actions
don't rely on just one indicator for
example
when communicating a status such as a
success or error
include an additional design change
beyond simply color
when the design is implemented there are
guidelines in place for developing
accessible websites if you're interested
in the coding details
check out the teacher's notes in the
upcoming video
we'll learn some terms that will help us
talk about typography and typefaces
now that you understand what typography
is let's talk about some of the terms
used to describe its different elements
this will include typefaces parts of
letters
layouts and more instead of ambiguously
trying to describe something
like that low swoopy part of the
lowercase y
these terms will make it much easier to
know what you're talking about as we
dive into typography let's look at the
numerous elements that shape a typeface
first we have the cap height this is
simply the height of the capital letters
next is the baseline which is pertinent
to both the uppercase and lowercase
letters
as it's the guideline for which the
majority of characters rest
the height of the lowercase letter set
is determined by the lowercase
x so this is labeled as the x height
the x height varies across typefaces and
can greatly affect legibility
let's look at that a high x height means
the lowercase is larger in relation to
the upper case
whereas a low x height means the
opposite it's smaller
when smaller font sizes come into play a
typeface with a high x height can help
retain legibility
because the lowercase is larger in
relation to the upper case
let's say you have two different
typefaces and both are set at 12 point
size
one could be easier to read than the
other due to the higher
x height you'll also notice there are
certain areas where some lowercase
letters
descend below the baseline and others
ascend
above the x height these are called
descenders and ascenders respectively
the p here has a descender and the d
has an ascender you might be wondering
how low can descenders go
or how high can ascenders climb
well that also varies across typefaces
in some typefaces ascenders climb up
above the cap height
and others they sit below and in some
cases the cap height
and ascenders are aligned this last case
though can affect readability
and letter recognition for instance
let's say you're using helvetica where
the cap height and the ascender height
are similar
you're writing out a headline which
includes the word
ill the uppercase i
and these two lowercase l's are hard to
tell apart
some might read that as ill but others
might read it as the roman numeral three
this would be even harder to decipher if
the letters appeared
mixed up in a coupon code where
uppercase
lowercase and numbers are present
i'm not saying don't use helvetica or
typefaces with a similar cap and
ascender height
i'm saying pay close attention to your
ascenders and descenders
and know what's at stake let's move on
to the next
term the typeface we are currently
looking at
has serifs on it serifs are projections
that finish off the main strokes of a
letter
they can sometimes add legibility and
letter recognition
for example the problem we just
encountered with the ill
would not happen here because the serifs
are distinctly different on those two
letters
distinctive character shapes help
differentiate letters
and serifs help letters flow the shape
of letters
particularly helps those with dyslexia
and reading disabilities
other typefaces forego serifs on their
letter forms
these are called sans serifs sans
meaning without
next let's talk about contrast contrast
can relate to a few different things
in typography the first deals with the
actual letter forms in a typeface
a typeface with high contrast would have
thick vertical strokes
and then horizontal strokes
a typeface with low contrast would have
little to no difference in stroke
thickness
contrast can also refer to the actual
text
and how it relates to the background
pure black text on a pure white
background creates high contrast
whereas a light gray on a medium gray
creates low contrast
later we'll look at when creating high
or low contrast is appropriate
according to the wcag contrast
guidelines
body text color should have a contrast
ratio of at least
4.5 to 1 when compared to its background
color large text that is 18 points and
larger
should have a contrast ratio of at least
three to one
lastly let's discuss color
like contrast color can mean a few
different things in typography
the first is the simplest and is
probably what comes to your mind
it's the actual color of text such as
red
blue yellow etc
we can create page contrast with changes
in color
common color blindness conditions
include
red green and blue yellow
people with color blindness have
difficulty discerning the differences
between the
two therefore avoid pairing
color text and backgrounds in those
colors
there are browser plugins and other
tools which allow you to test how those
with color blindnesses see your design
check out the teacher's notes for links
the second meaning refers to the overall
density of ink or text on a page
if we want we can utilize different
weights of the typeface
at different sizes to create even color
on a page
we have lighter weights at larger sizes
and regular weights at smaller sizes
or we can create uneven color by setting
our headings to be bolder weights
while keeping the paragraphs the same
these heavy areas of color can create
emphasis
if needed when we use this term
we'll distinguish its context to avoid
confusion
there are many other terms used to
describe different parts of letter forms
and typography
if you're hungry for more you can also
check out the teachers notes
which includes links to a couple of
glossaries
with what we know now from this video
we'll be able to better
understand the different types of type
in our next video
now let's look at the different
classifications or
types of typefaces you might be
wondering
why is this important can't i just find
something i like and use it
well i'm glad you asked knowing
different type genres will help you
choose a proper typeface for the
projects at hand
and make you a better designer for
instance
if you're working with a client who
wants the mood of their site to
convey eloquence you need to know what
classes or styles of typefaces lean
towards that bent
or if you're designing a site that's
heavily influenced by a certain time
period you should utilize a typeface
that would have been appropriate to
genres at that time
as i mentioned earlier typefaces have a
mood or personality
the way their characters look conveys a
message to the reader
knowing these genres will help us see
how our type is talking
and what makes it distinct so without
further ado
let's dive in type has been classified
in different ways over the years
but for simplicity's sake we'll look at
three major genres
serif sans serifs and scripts along with
their sub-genres
up first we'll look at serif typefaces
like we learned from our terminology
typefaces can have serifs on their
letter forms
and this would place them in the serif
genre
simple enough but within this genre we
have a number of nuances that will set
apart
different serifs into sub-genres the
sub-genres we'll be covering
are humanist old style transitional
d-don and after the invention of the
printing press in 1450
logically the creation of typefaces
shortly followed
humanist typefaces arose around the
1460s and 1470s
with strong calligraphic influence
printers were creating typefaces based
on the strokes of a pen
when drawing letter forms they tend to
have diagonal stress
lower stroke contrast and a relatively
small
x height serifs are not as refined
these are not as common today but some
examples are jensen
kennerly and centaur old style came
about next in the latter part of the
15th century
the letter forms were getting more
refined as type and
less influenced by calligraphy we see
less diagonal stress happening and the
serifs have also changed to be more
wedge-like some examples include
gaudy old style palatino perpetua
and plantain this brings us to the 18th
century where we see transitional
typefaces
on the rise the trend of decreasing
calligraphic flow continues
and here we have vertical stress thinner
and flatter serifs along with
exaggerated contrast between thicks and
thins
some examples include baskerville
bookmen
and clearface itc next
we have the done typefaces arriving in
the late 18th century
the influence of the pen is really
nowhere to be found
the serifs have become even thinner
without any sign of bracketing
contrast is taken to the extreme with
thick verticals
and ultra thin horizontals you might
regard these typefaces as reminiscent of
the high
fashion culture they work great at large
sizes with ample amounts of white spaces
around them
but as body copy at small sizes their
serifs and horizontals can quickly get
lost
some examples include bodhani and dido
now we'll head in the opposite direction
with slab serifs
who have extremely thick slab-like
serifs
and low contrast these came about in the
early 19th century
and were heavily used for headlines and
advertising
because of their bold look at me
appearance
most of these are utilized at large
sizes but a few have been known to
also work well in small text sizes
some examples of these include rockwell
claridin and egypteen next let's move
into the new genre of sans serifs
these typefaces do not have serifs on
their letter forms
or literally are without serifs
we'll look at grotesque neo-grotesque
humanist and geometrics in the late 19th
century
we see the rise of grotesque sans serifs
though we see sans serifs as completely
normal today
don't forget that there wasn't much of a
reference for them when they came about
the design of an earlier one axon daw's
grotesque
has actually been theorized to be
derived from didone
because the typefaces have similar
metrics when the serifs from d'done are
removed
as we'll see in other genres sans serifs
are typically low contrast
some examples of grotesque also include
franklin gothic
the neo-grotas then arises refining some
of the peculiarities in early grotesques
these are some of the more common
sans-serif typefaces
and helvetica fits right in there
although there is a desire for
simplicity here
these aren't always great candidates for
body copy because of simplicity
and similarity in letter forms can often
affect legibility at small sizes
other examples include univer
next we have humanist sands not to be
confused with humanist
serifs and these get back to some
calligraphic roots
with greater variations in line widths
these are often the most legible of the
sans-serif bunch
hence their popular use as website body
copy
so you may be wondering why are they
more legible
first the modulation of the line
thickness creates distinct character
shapes
this makes it easier to distinguish so
it's easier to recognize
words second humanist letter forms have
wide apertures which for example
helps us to avoid confusing a lowercase
e
as an o examples of humanist serifs
include tahoma
gill sands and fruity gear next we have
our geometrics
which are quite popular today as the
name implies
their letter forms are based on
geometric shapes
like circles and squares examples
include futura bank gothic and gotham
now we'll move into our final genre of
scripts
which are typefaces based on handwriting
we'll subset this genre into formal and
casual scripts
formal scripts are based on letter forms
from writing masters in the 17th and
18th centuries
they have some contrast between thick
and thin
as they were inspired by the way a quill
or nimble pen would handle the letter
forms
they tend to be more elegant and work
well for events like weddings today
casual scripts are a bit freer and well
casual they tend to be more lighthearted
or easygoing than their serious
eloquent counterparts the contrast can
range from
low to high depending on the typeface
they were often inspired by the way a
brush or marker would handle the letter
forms
alright that was a lot to cover i hope
it helps you get to know type a little
better
so we can make smarter choices down the
road
also think about if there is a certain
genre that you naturally gravitate
towards
in the next video we'll look at
designing for print versus digital
when laying out or setting type for
print the process yields a tangible
document such as a piece of paper
which has the text as ink on a page this
final medium
is quite different than a lighted screen
displaying a certain amount of pixels to
render type on a website
now let's look at two main ways web
typography differs from print
and how we can smartly design with that
in mind
first let's talk about desktop fonts
versus web fonts
desktop fonts are used for print layouts
and design
they are fonts you install on your
computer which gives you the ability to
use them in word processing programs or
design
programs the final mediums they can end
up on
are pages of paper posters billboards
jpegs pngs the list goes on
desktop fonts were made with those
mediums in mind
web fonts are font files that are not
intended to be used in the same way that
desktop fonts are
web fonts are created for the purpose of
serving up a font on a website or app
that might not be installed on a
person's computer
this is crucial when designing for the
web we'll get into where to find web
fonts in a bit
but for now just know there are several
websites that let you download web fonts
for free
or for purchase in the distant past
when creating a website you could only
use fonts that were already native to
the person's computer
also known as system fonts the upside of
using system
fonts is there's no loading time the
fonts are designed for legibility on the
devices
and users have a familiarity with the
font
however it limits your choices because
you have to use fonts that are native to
multiple operating systems
on windows and mac now that web fonts
are common and well supported
you have more control and customization
over what your users see
when designing for a mobile app the
easiest option is to use a system font
but if you prefer a custom font look for
fonts with an
app license this makes it easy to use
the font
across ios android and other digital
publishing platforms
when shopping for a web font be sure to
inform the client about the ongoing cost
some web font licenses are charged based
on the number of monthly active users
sometimes you'll have a larger budget
for web fonts
which provides you with some flexibility
and options to choose from
other times there might not be room in
the budget for web font licenses
or subscription models if that's the
case
try to help the client understand the
benefits of good typography
and why there is a cost associated with
web fonts
for example i might tell a client free
typefaces
are fine to use and i will happily go
down that route if needed
but be aware there's a relatively small
number of really good versatile free
fonts
which limits our options because of that
the good ones are often used on many
sites
which won't do us any favors in
distinguishing your site
to set your site and brand apart i would
recommend going with a subscription
web font model although there is some
cost i think your brand and users will
get
much more mileage out of paid web fonts
than if we went with free fonts
after that sometimes a client makes room
in the budget
and sometimes they don't in the latter
case we'll want to have
all these principles we discussed in the
back of our minds
as we browse free web font sites to find
good ones
another thing to note about web fonts is
this
some popular typefaces have desktop
licenses
but may not yet be available as web
fonts
in this case you should reach out to the
type designer or foundry
to see if you can purchase a web font
license or find out when one will be
released
do not try to use a desktop license font
and convert it to a web font
or serve up desktop font files on your
site
not only is this not smart but it's also
breaking the license agreement for most
typefaces
lastly let's discuss another difference
which is
fixed layouts versus fluid layouts
in print or graphic design you're
designing for a fixed layout
meaning the type and elements are
arranged in a specific way
that's locked into the medium for
example
if i was laying out a magazine article
the type is set in a specific place
with an exact width and link to the
block of text
once that magazine is finalized and
printed
the type and layout remain that way so
you know exactly how the reader is going
to see it
with the web it's much different users
may be viewing your site
on a phone tablet or desktop which
all have different screen sizes
typography that
might work great when viewing the site
on a desktop computer
could take a turn for the worse on a
mobile phone
with responsive design we can create
fluid layouts
so that our type and layouts can respond
to a user's screen size
this gives us a ton of control such as
changing
font sizes layouts widths and more
at certain break points we'll discuss
this more later
that's it for now and good work
finishing this stage
i'll see you in the next stage where
we'll look at how to choose and use
typefaces
[Music]
with all this talk about fonts you're
probably itching to get some new ones of
your own
you're probably familiar with the
standard set of fonts that come on your
computer
these are called system fonts and
android
ios windows and mac each have a
different selection
these are immediately usable on your
computer although there is a relatively
small selection
if you do decide to design with a system
font
when it's time to develop it with code
you can either find a web font that
allows
everyone to see the font even if they
don't have it installed
or you can create what's called a font
stack in your code
it's a list that tells the browser which
fonts to use
for example you may prefer helvetica
which is available on all macs but not
all windows computers
so you can add arial as a fallback which
is available on nearly every windows
computer
luckily system fonts aren't the only
option
there are tons of fonts available for
download and they're easy to install
here's how to install a font find a font
foundry or font distributor website
then sort by the features you're looking
for
more on that later when you find the one
download and install it on your computer
you may notice there is more than one
file per
font style this can happen if there are
different formats
here are the common font formats open
type
truetype eot woof
wolf2 and svg
files with an otf extension are open
type fonts
this is the preferred format because it
includes the most customization options
and has widespread support across
platforms
files with a ttf extension are true type
fonts this is what was used before the
open type format
while they still work well they don't
have the extras that opentype fonts have
files with an eot extension use a format
created by microsoft
they're meant to be used on the web
however they only work in internet
explorer
wolf files are the preferred format for
web fonts
these files are compressed which means
they load faster
wolf 2 is a newer iteration of woof the
difference is that they're more
compressed
it's well supported across all the major
browsers
if you're targeting internet explorer or
older browser versions
wolfe has the most support
svg fonts are not recommended unless
you're trying to support
very old versions of safari
check out the teacher's notes for
websites where you can find fonts to
download
good typography starts with choosing a
good typeface
no matter how nice graphical elements
look on a page
a choice of a bad typeface can quickly
ruin it
when entering into the process of
choosing a typeface
first ask yourself where will it appear
well
on the web duh but where on the web
what's the context will it be in the
navigation
or in the paragraphs or in the headlines
or all of those
answers to these questions will
determine if you're looking for a text
type face that is engineered for small
sizes to a variety of settings
or a display typeface which tends to be
more flashy and works well at larger
sizes
these two descriptors deal with the size
and function for which a typeface is
intended
in the next two videos we'll look at how
to choose a text typeface and a display
typeface
it's often smart to choose a text
typeface before a display
because much of the copy on a site will
be set in this choice
in his pocket guide on combining
typefaces tim
brown calls on your anchor typeface
because it acts as a reference point for
every element in your composition
he encourages you to make your body text
the anchor if possible
so when choosing a text typeface on the
web
your first priority is legibility if a
site's body copy is hard to read
then visitors won't stick around for
long
let's look at a few things to consider
in determining if a typeface has good
legibility
and readability first does the typeface
have a good
x height an x height that's too low will
make the lowercase letters hard to read
and tell apart at small sizes an x
height can also be
too high if it's nearing the cap height
making it hard to discern
what's uppercase and what's lowercase
a general measurement to go by is if the
x height is around
60 to 75 percent of the cap height
then you've got yourself a good
candidate for a text-based
next let's consider the white space
around the letter forms
and its impact on legibility if the
space between letters
also known as letter spacing is too
narrow or too tight
then at smaller sizes the letters can
get muddled together
which hurts legibility looser letter
spacing
also allows the letter forms to still
breathe at small sizes
while we do have some control over
letter spacing with code it's not
advisable to manually letter space body
text
find a typeface that already has proper
looser letter spacing for text
next you will want to make sure the
typeface has overall even color
as it balances the positive space of
characters
and the negative space of white space
you wouldn't want your text to feel
too dense in certain areas or characters
which can break the reading flow
a trick you can employ is to blur your
eyes as you're looking at the typeface
we'll manually mimic that here do any
dark splashes or uneven places of color
show up
if so you probably want to mark that one
off the list
avenir next looks quite even though
other areas that deal with white space
are counters
a counter is the fully or partially
closed white space
inside letter forms like o b or e
large or open counters can also aid
legibility
because they are less prone to close up
at smaller sizes
let's look at nutraface tube by house
industries
as an example on x height and white
space
this family comes with a text and a
display version
both of them here are set at the same
point size
but we can immediately notice some
differences
though the cap heights are similar the
text version has a higher x height
which helps retain legibility at smaller
sizes
the letter spacing is looser in the text
version than in the display version
giving the characters encounters more
room to breathe
although the display face wouldn't work
well at small sizes
its lower x height and tighter letter
spacing
helps greater amounts of text fit into
tighter spaces
a trait that's beneficial for headlines
next you want to think about the mood of
the typeface matching the content at
hand
familiarize yourself with the content by
taking the time to read it thoroughly
then write down some ways to describe it
in your own words
is it serious light-hearted witty
pointed classy as you peruse typefaces
have these words in the back of your
mind and see if a typeface speaks in
that certain mood
consider who your audience is and what
kinds of styles of typefaces they might
be accustomed to
are they doctors lawyers kids
are there certain genres that the target
industry is known for
you might not want to choose something
that's been overused
but you can still plan to these norms
and create familiarity
or untrust by choosing a proper type
base that speaks in the right mood
with text faces it should be noted that
mood can be conveyed with the slightest
subtleties in the letter forms
a simple change in the way a serif is
handled can mean the world of a
difference in text
because there's a lot of it on the page
don't go for something that's
overly ornate or has a lot of character
as it'll have too much going on for body
copy
in any case the mood of the typeface
should fit the content at hand
but don't sacrifice legibility just
because you like the mood of another
typeface better
don't forget to make sure the typeface
has everything you need
you would hate to get halfway through
designing a layout
and realize the font doesn't contain a
certain character or symbol that's
needed
things to consider are does the typeface
have a range of weights
does the typeface have italic styles
well we need different widths for
versatility
are small caps necessary what accented
characters are included for language
support
and what kinds of numerical figures are
needed
to clarify that last note there are a
few different styles of numerical
figures
we'll look at old style and lining
figures
old style figures vary in height and
descend below the baseline at times
these are nice for text and body copy as
they flow well with the rhythm set by
the text
and they're necessary when using small
caps
lining figures all have the same height
and baseline
and are generally good for display
headlines or
setting with uppercase only
that concludes how to choose a text
typeface
sometimes designers utilize a versatile
text family
that works for both small and large text
sizes
other times a single typeface won't work
for all text sizes
because weird intricacies can appear in
the letter forms at different sizes
also you might just want to have some
variety with your type so
in the next video we'll look at how to
choose a display typeface
for further study on choosing a typeface
there's some great articles and
resources in the teachers notes
that influence what we discussed here
and i highly recommend taking some time
to read them
now that we understand how to anchor our
content with a text typeface
let's see how to go about choosing a
display face for the web
as we saw earlier display typefaces are
meant for larger sizes like big
headlines
site titles or pull quotes this allows
for a bit more expressive and creative
opportunities with letter forms
nice intricacies like thin serifs would
be lost at small point sizes
but here they can shine big
bold condensed decks with narrow
counters would close up
at body text sizes but here you can soak
them all
in a nice casual sign painter script
would hardly be legible in paragraphs
but
here it can flow beautifully as a
heading
so how should we go about choosing one
first make sure it's legible and
readable
just because the type is bigger doesn't
mean that every character of a typeface
will be legible
if a person can't read a headline or a
title
then the message hasn't been enhanced by
good typography
it's been lost by bad typography
although there's much more room for
expression with display type
make sure you're choosing a
well-designed legible typeface
just because something looks cool in a
specimen image doesn't mean it'll be
usable
make use of the tests we talked about by
blurring your eyes to see if a typeface
has an
even overall color in all of its
characters
most font sites include a type tester
with their typefaces
write out example headlines to make sure
it's evenly spaced
and see what sizes it works best at
display type should have a bit tighter
spacing than text typefaces
other things that can help readability
and display faces
are short ascenders and descenders in
the setting of headlines
these features help reduce choppiness in
the text
again one of the big questions we'll
want to ask is
does the mood of the typeface fit the
content for text faces we talked about
channeling the mood with subtle nuances
in typefaces
with display we have a bit more room for
expressiveness in the mood
we can use the words we came up with
throughout our content exercise in the
previous video
and apply them to our search for a
display face that fits the right mood
if you're creating a site that's set
around a certain time period
look for typefaces that are true to that
period
that will take some research but instead
of choosing the mood we think the period
should look like
we'll be truly conveying what it was
like
jessica hish has some great thoughts on
this which are linked to in the teachers
notes
next we'll again want to think about who
are our readers or users
if we're creating a site for people in a
specific industry
let's say web developers then that
affects how we choose a typeface
take for instance this example of how to
play into the typographic styles
people in the web design industry aren't
accustomed to
let's say we want to display snippets of
example code in a blog post
coding programs like atom or sublime
text
are used by web developers and default
to monospace typefaces
these are fonts originally created for
typewriters
whose characters all occupy the same
amount of horizontal space
they're great for code since it's easier
to distinguish symbols
and layout tabular data in plain text
but they wouldn't be a great choice for
body text due to decreased legibility
and long paragraphs
we can still play into that industry
norm with our code snippets though
by utilizing a mono-spaced font we can
typographically
make the snippet appear as it would in
an actual code environment
so take into account who your readers
are and what styles of typefaces
might be the right fit for their
industry
i won't fully go into the other
priorities again as they were covered in
the previous video
but similarly to text typefaces take
into account the budget
and make sure a display face has
everything you need
in regards to weights styles or accents
because display typefaces are used in
fewer contacts
there's a bit more flexibility here
though you'd never want to set
body text in all caps you can actually
utilize a display face to great effect
that only has uppercase characters
also it's possible to have good
typography with a single weighted font
for your display face these situations
might not be ideal but they can be
worked through
lastly there might be a scenario where
you land a client who
already has a typeface for their brands
this process then is sometimes as simple
as finding the webfont version of that
typeface
but other times there might not be web
font licenses available for it yet
in that case you want to find a typeface
that channels a similar mood and style
to the print version
as you translate their brand for the web
you could google alternative to insert
typeface here
but what's the fun in that utilize
all the knowledge you've taken here to
make a well-informed decision for an
alternative that
best spends the client you might arrive
at a different conclusion than those
online forums
later on in the course we'll get into
more details on how to pair typefaces
but i hope this has helped distill some
of the ambiguity
around choosing a typeface for the web
think about where it's going to live
what makes it legible if it's mood
matches the content and audience
does it have everything you need and
what factor will cosplay
this is by no means an exact science so
have some fun along the way the answers
to these questions
should help guide you in a good
direction and leave room for your own
personal taste and design choices
next we'll take a look at weights styles
and sizes
[Music]
now that we've looked at some principles
and have a background in typography
we'll get into how to practically
achieve good typography on the web in
the next few stages
in the previous stage we learned how to
choose fonts
in this session we'll start with the
basics of a font family's weights and
styles
like bold and italics first
it'll be good to mention here that faux
bold and faux italic are faux pas
which simply translates to don't do them
faux bold or faux italic means it is a
false bold or
fake italic these can occur when you
only have one
weight and style of a typeface design
programs in css
have the ability to fake the bold or
italic style of that web font
but believe me it ain't pretty and it
can hinder legibility
a faux bold is created by thickening up
the original font
this can create issues with legibility
as counters close up
dark patches of color can appear and
letters get distorted
type designers carefully craft their
bold weights to correct these issues
faux italic text is created by obliquing
or slanting the original font to a
certain degree
at first glance you might think this
looks okay
but let's take a closer look italic
versions of serif typefaces
are actually created in a more cursive
style
they're not just slanted versions of
their regular or
roman counterparts their condensed sum
and often their letter forms are
entirely different altogether
notice the changes here such as how the
crossbar on the e
becomes more fluid or how the f
elegantly descends below the baseline
because italics are often used for
emphasis on the web
true italics can better emphasize words
or phrases than
faux italics because of this for sans
serifs
this curse of nature is less accentuated
so you might think that you can get away
with the foe
but you can't any time you oblique the
font
the weight of the letter forms gets
unevenly distributed
which creates uneven color also
certain letters can change entirely in a
true italic
such as a two-story roman a changing to
a one-story italic a again
type designers meticulously build italic
versions of their fonts
correcting these issues so be sure to
utilize fonts that have
bold and italics instead of trying to
fake it
this not only gives the user a better
experience
but it also improves the legibility and
readability
be aware too that some typefaces online
are sold as having italics
but really they're just uncorrected
oblique versions of their fonts
this is why when we discussed using a
typeface
you'll want to make sure it's well built
with all the necessary weights and
styles
let's unpack that sometimes typefaces
have
a basic array of weights like normal and
bold
but other times a family of fawns can
range from
thin to light to normal to semi-bold to
bold
to black let's look at the different
weights of open
sands using figma as you can see
there's light light italic regular
italic and so on some fonts have
additional styles such as hairline
which is even thinner than thin an ultra
which is even
thicker than extra bold or black for
this entire text block
the family name is said as open sans
but the text within is a different
weight and or
style click into the text to see what
it's set to
if you see a message about missing fonts
download
all the styles of open sans from google
fonts
figma just has a few styles
pre-installed
in addition to those settings we can
also make the text underlined
we can format it in all caps this is
preferable to typing it in
all uppercase letters it's much easier
to switch back to title case if you
decide to change it later
we can also format it in small caps
but only if the font supports it we see
here
that open sans doesn't support small
caps
let's see it in playfair a google font
that supports small caps
be careful to not choose four small caps
as we want the true small caps designed
by the type designer
great now you've gotten a handle on the
basic formatting options
next i'll introduce you to the design
project we'll work on in this course
as i introduce concepts i'll demo it in
a design program called
figma to follow along download the
project
files here we see copy from the science
fiction book
the war of the worlds i've also added
some headings
the text is set in alegria from google
fonts
i chose this typeface because of its
roots and literature
due to the continent hand being a book
its diverse weights
italics and the inclusion of small caps
and other features
we'll use this file to play around with
type
as you can see all the text is the same
size
which really flattens the hierarchy
i can make the headings bold to stand
out but
there's even more we can do
let's talk about text size when
designing for screens in a design
program
you'll specify text in pixels a pixel is
a fixed unit of measure that pertains to
media
with display screens such as a computer
a good rule of thumb is to set your body
text anywhere relative to 16 pixels to
24 pixels
reader's eyes are usually a few feet
away from the screen
so these larger sizes are necessary for
comfortable reading
whereas smaller attacks can strain and
tire their eyes
this range is diverse too as every
typeface is different
as we've seen before the x height of a
typeface can
greatly affect its perceived size so
use what you've learned and make a
judgment call on what works best
when in doubt lean towards the larger
size to be safe
as the design gets implemented with code
the text size will likely translate to a
non-fixed
unit while pixels make it easy to create
exact designs with a fixed unit
designs are viewed on a broad range of
devices out in the wild
but because this is a fixed unit of
measure it can create
more work with responsive typography
which scales text size
up or down depending on the screen's
size
so pixels should be swapped out with
responsive units like
m's and rims which are relative units
for font sizing
this is incredibly helpful scalable and
powerful for responsive typography
but no need to act on that now we'll
work in pixels as we design
and if you decide to develop with code
you can do so with relative units and
minds
once you've set your body text size it's
time to adjust the rest of the text
sizing your headings paragraphs and
other text elements
may seem a little tricky and it's not a
great idea
to just guess by shooting in the dark
this can lead to inconsistent
headings and paragraph sizes which is
why following a typographic scale can
help immensely
a scale gradually increases at a certain
rate
to ensure consistent proportions for
your font sizes
the classic typographic scale increases
in
intervals of 1 2 3 and then 12.
it's been used for centuries and is
reliable to adhere to
especially if you're using 16 pixels as
your base size
16 pixels is great but i'd like to
enlarge the body copy to 20 pixels
that size is not in the classic scale
but don't fret
i'll look at typescale.com to build a
typescale
this site is incredibly helpful because
you can set your base size
test different scales and even import
google web fonts our base size is 20
pixels
let's choose the major third as i like
its sizing
and we can change the font family to
alegria
feel free to test out the different
scales to see what they look like
the perfect fourth and fifth are also
commonly used
we're now given some sizes in m's and
pixels
focus on pixels for now ms are important
when it comes to implementing it
code now let's set the font size for the
headings
here's the order of the headings by text
size title
paragraph headings and author name for
simplicity
i'll round down to the nearest pixel
also
note that you don't need to use the
largest text size
you can start and stop anywhere within
the scale
so long as you choose adjacent sizes
the largest heading will be our h1 or
heading 1
at 48 pixels the next will be our h2
at 39 pixels and the third will be our
h3 at 31 pixels
then i'll set the body text to 20 pixels
i'll go ahead and create a text style
for each heading
this sets us up for quick edits later on
and it keeps the text sizes consistent
great now that's set up we still have a
ways to go
but getting a proper body size and scale
is a great place to start
once we get a good size for our body
text we'll want to take a look at our
measure and space
we first talk about measure which is
also known as
line length because it deals with how
many characters fit on each line of text
then we'll discuss the space between
letters
these two concepts both work together to
create readable layouts
which give the type room to brief
in elements of typographic style robert
bringhurst recommends a measure of 45 to
75 characters
per line for a single column of text
a measure that's too long can tire out
reader's eyes
as they have to travel far across the
screen and back multiple times
when shifting to the next line below
they can potentially lose their place
a measure that's too short will have
readers eyes quickly jumping back and
forth to the next line
which is again quite exhausting and
jarring
a measure that's just right will be
comfortable to the user
creating an enjoyable reading experience
remember 45 to 75 characters works well
with the mid 60s being ideal
if you're working with multiple columns
you can shoot for the 40 to 50 character
range
in our figma file our layout currently
isn't very readable the lines of text
span the whole page
and the measure is well above what's
recommended
i've placed bold asterisks at the 45th
and 75th characters
we can remove this later but this guides
us and gives us a good idea about where
our line should break
to determine character counts check out
the teacher's notes for a tool
if these two asterisks end up on the
same line
then we know we need to fix our measure
now let's determine a good width for
this text
a good place to start is to multiply
your body font size by 30.
since the body font size is 20 pixels
we could set a max width of 600 pixels
the asterisks fall on two different
lines which is what we want
and the text width feels appropriate
always take time to read through a few
paragraphs to make sure the measure
feels appropriate or
needs adjusting although commonly
confused
tracking and kerning are two different
techniques when it comes to typography
they both deal with the space around the
letter forms
but in different ways we'll examine each
one
along with general rules of thumb for
both
tracking also known as letter spacing
pertains to the amount of space between
every character in a particular block of
text
you could increase or decrease the
amount of tracking
which will affect the text as a whole
tighter tracking will result in a
heavier feel
whereas looser tracking gives it a
lighter
airier look for example
let's set the title in all caps to make
a bold statement
now we'll want to tweak the tracking to
make it easier to read
we can set the tracking in our main
title to be greater or less than the
font's normal spacing
let's add 3 percent to the heading 1
style
notice how every space between every
character is affected
as it loosened up now
let's change the value to a negative
value of negative 3
which will track it inward
looks good notice how this also affects
how heavy the element feels on the page
tighter letter spacing will result in
heavier feel
whereas looser letter spacing gives it a
lighter
airier look general rules of thumb
are slightly reduce the tracking and
headings by
three to five percent as type gets
bigger
the tracking increases sometimes
in headings it appears too spaced out
tightening the heading to be more
compact makes it more solid and more
closely resemble the spacing of body
type
this is also commonly done to logo types
do not change the tracking and body copy
unless it's
absolutely necessary to aid legibility
don't track your type out too much as
words and spaces will get muddled
increase tracking in small caps or
uppercase texts
by five to ten percent this generally
applies to uppercase headlines
acronyms and long series of digits
if your design program gives you the
option of metric or
optical tracking choose metric which
uses character spacing information
inside the font
this is valuable information the font
designer included
optical spacing throws out that
carefully crafted information
and instead uses an algorithm that tries
to guess the kerning of every character
and often gets it wrong now let's look
at kerning
kerning deals with the amount of space
between a specific character combination
rather than the spacing of a whole body
of text
in a typeface a type designer sets the
space for the left side of a letter
and the right side of the letter so that
it works best with
all the other letters and their spacing
certain character combinations can come
up that are either
too far apart or too close together
such as uppercase av
uppercase wa or uppercase t
lowercase a with kerning
character pairs are adjusted to be
evenly spaced with the rest of the
typeface
generally you wouldn't need to adjust
kerning if you have a well-designed font
if you find off-balance letters you can
manually adjust the kerning
but if you find a lot then consider
switching to a more balanced font
so letter spacing affects the spacing of
the text as a whole
whereas kerning deals with the space
between a specific pair of letters
now let's move into talking about
ligatures
ligatures improve the appearance of text
for letters that are too close together
like the f and the i they create a
smoother transition between letters
by connecting certain character
combinations they can also give the text
a nice touch
ligatures are mostly found in serif and
script typefaces
because they aren't as necessary in sans
serifs
so just because a typeface does not have
them
does not mean it's a bad typeface
in order to utilize ligatures you'll
need a typeface that supports them
typeface specimen images will often
showcase them
or you can look through the character
map on a typeface to see if they're
available
here i'm viewing brandontax font on
myfonts.com
under open type features i see it has
ligatures
to see it in action i can type the word
figs
see how the f and i letters combine
the type designer decided to hide the
dot of the eye
when it follows a lowercase f this helps
legibility
and simplifies the text
that's it for horizontal space stick
around for the next video where we'll
delve into vertical space
now let's address the vertical space in
our design
by adjusting our line heights and
looking at vertical rhythm
leading also referred to as line height
or line spacing
deals with the vertical space between
consecutive lines of text you might be
familiar with it
as single or double spacing and document
editors like
word for reference i've seen well-built
typographic sites utilize line heights
ranging from 135 percent to 185 percent
for body text every typeface is
different
so line heights can vary 150
tends to be a good starting place and is
commonly used
figure out a good comfortable leading
for your body copy first
because it will be paramount to
establishing vertical rhythm
i'll use a hundred and sixty percent for
the body text
before we get into rhythm let's take a
look at our headings
i'll add a bit more text to make them
break to the next line so we can set
their line height
a general rule of thumb is as heading
sizes increase
your line height should decrease the
line height that worked for the body
would most likely be too spacious for
your bigger headings
here i'm setting our heading 1 at 110
percent
are heading two at 120 percent and are
heading three at 130 percent
different font sizes and families
require different values
so be sure to test what works best
great now that those are adjusted we can
look at our vertical rhythm
the space between paragraphs is decent
however
there's more we can do with grids we'll
get into that shortly
the spacing between lines of text
creates a rhythm that can balance a
layout and enhance readability
when we read we recognize patterns if a
layout has a consistent
line and paragraph spacing we develop
pattern recognition
after reading a few lines of text this
will help us identify
other identical spaces as part of the
same pattern
an unbalanced rhythm can disorient the
reader
vertical rhythm balances the spacing and
arrangement of text
as the user reads down the page every
bit of text has a baseline it sits on
if each line of text sits on the
rhythmic baseline
then you can say that it has consistent
vertical balance or rhythm
the concept of vertical rhythm applies
first and foremost
to paragraph text you can also utilize
headings
subheadings or images to flow in sync
with your rhythm
but it's often hard to perfectly execute
unless a site's content is static
robert bringhurst writes that headings
subheads
block quotations footnotes illustrations
captions and other intrusions into the
text create syncopations
and variations against the base rhythm
of regularly leaded lines
these variations can and should add life
to the page
but the main text should also return
after each variation
precisely on beat and in phase
that means it's okay if a heading or
image breaks rhythm a bit
but most important is your paragraph
text returning to its rhythm
after that element is introduced this
offers
consistent predictable line spacing as
the reader scrolls through the content
next we'll create a consistent rhythm
using a baseline grid grids create a
system for arranging content on a screen
this results in layouts with an inherent
rhythm
when space is divided into boxes content
can be contained in the rows and columns
or spread to fill multiple rows and
columns
there's a long history of grid systems
in graphic design
and we see them in web and app design as
well
designing for the web often involves
creating a design
that will work across multiple devices
as such while a website may allow for a
multi-column design
on a larger screen size such as a
desktop
the same website on a smartphone may
render as a single column
so it's easier to read within a limited
space
baseline grids divide the artboard in
relation to the elements on the page
we'll start by using layout grid and
figma
first select the frame now you'll see
the layout grid module appear
there are three different forms of grids
to choose from
grid column and row let's choose grid
which is a uniform grid that includes
columns and rows
the size refers to how many pixels apart
each baseline is
this should correspond to the line
height of our body text
as mentioned before our line height is
160
and the text size is 20 pixels
this means the line height comes out to
be 32 pixels
so that's what we'll want to set our
baseline to
notice how the lines of text are not
sitting on the baseline
but rather in between them and they're
not consistently in the same place
this is what we call poor rhythm let's
change that
to start let's get our title aligned
next we need to adjust the rest of the
text
we're able to add 30 pixels of spacing
in between paragraphs
but that's the limit to the control we
have if we keep all of this text in one
text box
so let's break these pieces out into
their own text boxes for more control
i've done that in this next artboard
now we can align them to the grid just
align them to the horizontal lines and
don't worry about the vertical lines
where the planet mars section starts
notice how i skip two rows of spacing to
give it
extra vertical spacing this makes it
clear a new section is starting
and keeps the headline close to its
corresponding intro paragraph
if i had left one row before and after
the heading
i'd run into a ux issue called floating
heading
this occurs when the vertical spacing
above and below a heading
makes it difficult to tell which heading
belongs to which series of paragraphs
alright great we see our rhythm stays
intact and we can
easily notice where another paragraph
starts a text indent is not necessary
for leading paragraphs
because their start already is
noticeable
let's take the baseline grid away to get
a final look
this page has much better rhythm now
keep in mind if we were to change any
font sizes
line heights or margins that will affect
vertical rhythm
grids are a tool to help us make good
design choices
but it isn't fail proof something could
be perfectly lined up to a baseline
but that doesn't mean it feels right go
with what feels right
this does take some tinkering but don't
lose sight of the forest for the trees
keep in mind your first priority is
making sure your body's rhythm works
well with its line height and paragraph
structure
and as a final note break the grid when
necessary
this makes a bold statement and is a
technique for making an element stand
out
have fun with it now that you have
experience using a baseline grid
let's delve deeper into setting
paragraphs
there are two main options for option
one you can simply use an
empty line to add space between the
paragraphs
that's how it is in our project right
now as for option two
you can indent the first line let's look
at some pointers
the recommended amount of indentation is
1m
or in other words the base size of the
body text
and now for some don'ts don't indent the
first line of the first paragraph
after a heading or after an image or
any other figure also don't add extra
space in between the paragraphs
let's see how this looks on our project
now i have two paragraphs in the same
text box
but i just want to apply paragraph
indentation to the second paragraph
remember leading paragraphs don't get
indented
so i'll split the second paragraph into
its own text box
then i'll set the paragraph indentation
to 20 pixels
remember this matches the body text size
and for good measure i'll remove the
paragraph spacing
then i'll turn the grid back on to align
everything again
it's up to you which option you prefer
just be consistent throughout the design
if you can get all these concepts down
it'll be no time before you're creating
typographically sound designs with good
scale
and rhythm alright i'll see you in the
next stage where we'll get into the
details of laying out type
[Music]
alright you made it this far good work
if all this talk about type hasn't
gotten you excited already
then just you wait in this stage we'll
look at the different ways you can
layout type in a design
first up is typographic hierarchy this
concept is
crucial to seamlessly guide readers
through a page's content
hierarchy helps users understand what
information is most important
to what's secondary tertiary and so
forth
in this video we'll look at how to do
this with weight
style size and position in the next
we'll continue on the theme of hierarchy
with color and pairing typefaces
before we jump in let's check out all of
these concepts in action
at creativemornings.com let's say i
wanted to watch this talk that meg lewis
did in minneapolis
immediately i'm presented with an array
of information that's been arranged
with hierarchy and minds first
my eyes gravitate towards what's biggest
boldest and darkest on the page
the speaker's name this is the most
important piece of information here
and creative morning lets you easily
know it
next my eyes naturally continue reading
and move
downward to the title of the talk this
is of next importance after the speaker
name
it's smaller but still prominent
my eyes are then drawn to the bright
block of color
holding the white text of the city code
it's a nice touch
after i've taken all that in and
considered if i'm still interested
then i can make my way down to the
smaller secondary information
and read more about the speaker and
where exactly the talk was
and some more information about what the
talk was about
we see bold type multiple sizes
different colors
different positions and different
typefaces
utilized to convey the hierarchy of
information on the page
the combination is not only useful to
the user
it's also downright good looking these
concepts can be incredibly powerful to
create useful
beautiful websites but they can also get
out of hand pretty fast if we don't know
what we're doing
before you begin styling anything it's
smart to familiarize yourself with the
site's content
to get an overall big picture of
everything involved
it's often helpful to sketch out a
wireframe and then go about
numbering content elements starting with
one
what's of most importance to what's of
next importance
and so forth until every piece of
content has been labeled
this system will inform us on how we can
utilize typography
to accentuate our different pieces of
content
we can create hierarchies simply by
waiting certain blocks of text
a reader's eyes will be drawn to the
bolder elements on the page
this hierarchy helps readers make
connections between the content
and relate certain sections
speaking of sections typography is as
much about the treatment of the text
as it is with the space surrounding the
text
thus the importance of white space
white space is empty space without
content
and it plays a key role in the
readability of a design
it gives the reader space to rest their
eyes which reduces the feeling of
information overload let's look at the
white space of the left and right of our
type
margins or padding should be used to
give your type room to breathe
if a sentence comes too close to another
element then it can disrupt the flow of
reading
white space is often underutilized in
web design
which results in cramped and cluttered
layouts
also it should be noted that white space
doesn't have to be white
if you have a dark background with
lighter text
we would still call that area around the
text white space
let's check out a good example of white
space
here's an article on it's nicethat.com
a creative inspiration blog it's about
polisher
a renowned graphic designer notice how
there are ample amounts of white space
around the type
the words are not closing in on borders
they're given room to live
and breathe as you can see white space
can clean up a design
and give it an elegant professional feel
it can also emphasize content
by framing it with an empty space now
watch as the white space changes as i
resize the browser window
the content shifts into one column and
the white space is maintained
although and different proportions to
fit comfortably on
mobile
alright now that certainly got me
excited about hierarchy
in the next video let's explore what we
can do with style
weight size and position typographic
hierarchy
seamlessly guides readers through a
page's content
bold weight text makes text stand out
more while
light text makes it recede in comparison
an italic style can also be utilized
to denote emphasis or set apart the text
for example
i can italicize the author's name to
differentiate it from the other body
text
a different weight or italic style can
be used to carry emphasis
but if you overuse it you can end up
with an unbalanced hierarchy
and layout where everything is important
so
in turn nothing is important watch out
for how dense your typographic color is
on the overall page size is next
and it can immensely help in guiding
your readers through your content
this is why headings have a larger check
size than paragraphs
while headings are often bold a bold
weight is not
always necessary to convey hierarchy
when size is utilized
base font sizes should be at least 14
pixels
lastly let's look at how position can be
utilized to present hierarchy
when we're discussing position we're
talking about the placement
and space around the type in relation to
the other elements or blocks of type
around it
let's look at a site that does this well
here's a conference website for black
futurism
the name of the event is big and bold
then my eyes are drawn to the dots where
i can check out the program schedule
the large days of the week make the
daily schedules clear
the spacing in between each session
easily separates the events
this is a great practical yet highly fun
and bold take on conference website
design
next let's look at a more experimental
design by jen
simmons it utilizes the position of type
to present hierarchy and differentiate
elements
when we arrive on the site we
immediately see the large
bauhaus headline then our eyes move to
the german word for exhibition
which is rotated 90 degrees in position
to the right of the red square
the intention of this design was to
position type in a
bold and unexpected way while using the
red square as a grounding focal point
which the typography dances around
let's jump back into our example now so
we're actually already utilizing
position to differentiate
our content and minor ways by separating
our headings and paragraphs from one
another when we looked at vertical
spacing
in the last stage i might want to
accentuate our title
and author name a bit more though so
let's see what we can do with its
position
i'll center align them and give them
some more padding
great because of its position a reader
can now engage this as separate from the
main text
which further establishes its hierarchy
the center align style is also nice
because it feels akin to the title of an
old book cover
positional hierarchy could also be
accomplished with borders or line rules
above around or below the type to
separate a piece of content from the
element around it
the possibilities are really countless
with hierarchy
so remember to not make typographic
choices
just because a good designer knows when
and why to say
yes or no to an idea have a reason
behind
why you're bolding or italicizing text
or
why you're increasing sizes or why
you're moving an element to a certain
place
while we're on the topic of positioning
let's cover alignment
text alignment can be justified or
unjustified
but unjustified is typically more
readable
justified text creates lines of text
which evenly touch
the left and right side of the column
it's commonly used in newspapers since
it's an efficient use of space
however this can create large unsightly
gaps
throughout the paragraph these are
referred to as rivers
because the end result might look like
several
rivers of white space flowing throughout
the text
this makes it difficult for people with
dyslexia
it's not clear where a line of text ends
which unfortunately
causes them to switch to the wrong line
if you must use justified text
turn on hyphenation which allows words
to break apart and prevent those awkward
gaps
left aligned text is the default the
words evenly align
on the left to form a hard line while
the right edge is soft and ragged
this allows the words to flow naturally
but
be aware of bad rags such as a wedge
shape that creates an unintentional
shape left align text can
sometimes create rags on the right side
which are uneven gaps
often caused by long words minor gaps
are expected
but gaping holes should be taken into
account
there's really no easy way to prevent
them but we can sometimes avoid them by
adjusting
font sizes and line lengths then there's
right aligned text
this is when words are evenly aligned on
the right
while ragged on the left since english
is red
left or right left align is more legible
for this language
while right align text can be a novel
change from the usual
it can be jarring centered text creates
a ragged line on the left
and the right if you use center text in
a layout
it's generally advisable to consistently
center align
all the text for long form text it can
be difficult to read
therefore i recommend that you don't
center aligned paragraphs longer than
three lines
that's it for the first part of
typographic hierarchy
i'll see you in the next video as we
dive more into the subject and look at
caps and color
we just looked at how we can create
typographic hierarchy
through weight style size and color
now we'll continue with that theme
seeing how we can establish it through
caps and color first let's talk about
caps and small
cap characters think about an email or
text you receive that was in all caps
that probably felt like someone was
either declaring something important or
shouting at you
right setting type and capital letters
can create emphasis
authority or hierarchy in your design if
you overuse them
or commit the hideous crime of setting
all your body copy in them
then legibility and readability will
seriously be compromised
they're best used in small doses like a
short headline or a title
and the navigation to give an official
look
we can also utilize small caps to spice
up and add hierarchy to a design
they're a little less in your face than
all caps
in case you're not familiar with small
caps they look like uppercase characters
created near a lowercase size often
slightly above the x height of a
typeface
they're not just scaled down versions of
the uppercase
their weight and spacing have been
finessed to match the overall font
some design programs have a way to fake
the small caps
but i don't recommend it like faux
weights and styles
and ain't pretty small caps are used for
abbreviations like
asap official titles like the president
of the united states
headings like the title for a post or
the opening line of a book chapter or
blog article
they work great with uppercase and
lowercase letters
along with old style figures they also
flow great in body copy
because of their less obtrusive nature
due to their height being closer to the
x height
let's see them in action on jessica
hish's site
she uses small caps to grade a veil as
she denotes the categories showcasing
her recent work
here she opens the paragraph with a line
set in small caps
and she also uses a nice job cap for the
beginning letter of the text
a drop cap is a large capital letter
that typically spans the height of two
or more lines of body text
we'll take note of this to use in our
design in just a bit
but first let's look at small caps to
use small caps
first make sure the font includes
support for small caps
the good news is that alegria the
typeface we've chosen
has small caps available in its sister
family alegria sc
let's use jessica's site as inspiration
and add small caps to the start of each
paragraph
small caps are typically applied to the
first line
or simply just the first complete
thought in the first line
with the text selected go to type
details and choose small caps from the
letter case section
oh yeah this is starting to jive really
well
let's add a drop cap to our text to give
it extra emphasis
and style there currently isn't an easy
way to do this in figma
you have to craft each piece
i started by breaking out the n into its
own text block
then i made its text size 108 pixels so
it spans three lines of text
next i duplicated the first part of the
paragraph
and cropped down the first three rows
i positioned the rest of the paragraph
underneath
now it appears as if it's wrapping
around the drop cap
it accentuates the first paragraph but
it's now the biggest piece of type on
the page
don't worry that'll soon change
let's look at how to utilize color with
type
first you'll want to make sure the text
color has good contrast with its
background color
if the contrast is too low then the type
and its background color will start to
blend together
making it hard to decipher if it's too
high then it can tire out a reader's
eyes due to the bright nature of screens
pure black and white work well together
in print
but on the web you should stick to a
subtle black when set on a white
background
and vice versa on this example page
the text has a hex color code of hashtag
333
which is a dark gray and the background
is an off-white color
at hashtag f9f9f9 almost all popular
content heavy websites
utilize a light background with dark
text for their main body copy
versus a dark background with light text
don't forget to take into account
colorblindness and accessibility with
this concept of contrast
look in the teacher's notes for a tool
that will allow you to test for color
contrast scores you'll want a score of
aaa for maximum legibility which is
especially helpful
for long form texts to be read for a
significant period of time
a score of a a is a good goal for body
text
a a large is the lowest amount of
contrast
needed for headlines or texts around 18
pixels
with typographic hierarchy more contrast
will grab attention
whereas subtler contrast will blend in
another way to think about this is the
primary or important pieces of content
should be easily noticed
whereas secondary pieces can blend more
with the design
alright let's jump back into the project
i want to give our title and author name
further distinction from the text
to do this i'll put a dark background
color behind the title
i'll use a rectangle
align it to the baseline grid
and set the fill to pound
1e1e1e and more subtle black
then i'll set the color of the type to
pound
f9f9f9 a more subtle white
then i'll just align this text back onto
the baseline
see how that looks
all right now i want to make the author
name a bit less prominent by changing
its color
to do that i'll set it to pound 99999
which is a mid-gray it's more subdued
yet still meets the accessibility
guidelines for text contrast
it scores at 5.85
great now our title is further
accentuated because its color contrast
is much higher than the author's name
the page is getting there but let's
spice it up a little more by adding a
burnt orangish red color to our heading
2.
with mars being the red planet i think
it's fitting
this color has good contrast with the
background
and distinguishes our headings further
while adding some variety to the design
i'll set the body text to a dark gray
pound 333
pure black on a white background is hard
on the eyes and the gray gives it some
nuance
i'm going to stop here with color as i
don't want to go overboard
too many colors can make it hard for
users to understand
typographic hierarchy and it can clutter
up a design
smart color hierarchy helps users
recognize patterns within the page
links should look like links and other
elements should not
if similar colors are used then users
may think something is clickable
when it in fact is not keeping heading
colors persistent
can also aid readers in recognizing them
quicker
just be sure to not only rely on color
when signifying status or interactions
multiple indicators make your design
more accessible
that's it for hierarchy remember it's
all about
balancing and utilizing these different
techniques wisely
block quotes headings metadata
navigation and more are all at your
disposal to style
so design wisely with a clear hierarchy
to close this session i want to give you
some encouragement
in an article on typekit frank chamero
says
i'd suggest that most great examples of
fine typography
are merely designs that have wise
typeface choices
savvy use of space and a clear hierarchy
that's echoed through the structure and
presentation of the text
you now know how to do all those things
with what you learned from the past few
stages
it'll take some practice for sure but
the groundwork is there
in the next video i'll cover layout
treatments
let's go beyond paragraphs any time
there's a list
you can opt to make it more engaging by
styling it as a bulleted or numbered
list
and pull quotes help break up the
monotony of long columns of text
while bringing emphasis to a message
punctuation requires characters to be
positioned
outside the margin edge this is commonly
used for pull quotes and bulleted lists
to create an even visual edge for
example
hanging quotes keep the left alignment
balanced so it increases readability in
the text
a quotation mark that is flush with the
text like we see here
can interrupt the left margin and
disrupt the rhythm for the reader
compared to the one that is not
to keep quotation marks clear of the
edges we can give the text a negative
text indent
we also have the option to hang the list
markers in lists
which can help the flow of text because
the margin edge is well defined
and continuous compared to one that is
indented
either one is acceptable so it's really
up to us to go with what feels right
text and list items should also be
consistently aligned
if a list item runs more than one line
of text
and isn't aligned well then renek flow
can be interrupted because our eyes look
for straight lines
make sure the list markers are away from
the edges of text
which will make for a much cleaner
reading experience
another layout trick is using horizontal
rules to create
clear sections of content a horizontal
rule is a divider that can spread across
a column
it can spread the full width or only
cover a portion
it can be a simple line or something
more ornate
check out this example by jules forest
the horizontal rule above and below the
pull quote
give the piece visual interest and
emphasize the quoted text
when combining text with an image play
around with how the text wraps around
the image
in addition to forming rectangular
paragraphs around an image
you can make the text glide along the
edge of the object in the image
check out this design by jen simmons the
text forms a rounded edge which wraps
around the tomato
finally the last example i want to show
you is tables
tables are an excellent way to show
tabular data
in columns and rows it helps readers
compare content
as it easily organizes data on the
screen
the trick with tables is to use borders
sparingly
check out the pricing table for slack
the columns are subtle
and the rows are more defined to help
you compare the features
lastly let's look at how we can
establish hierarchy by pairing different
typefaces
we talked about how to choose a typeface
earlier so we're working under the
understanding that we should pair it
based on the text typeface we've chosen
typeface pairs aren't always necessary
and
beginners are sometimes encouraged to
only use one typeface in order to really
learn the ins and outs of good
typography
until they're ready to start pairing
type you can start by staying within a
typeface and choosing different weights
or you can pair a sans serif with the
sarah from the same family
for example ff meta and ff meta serif
typography gets harder to execute well
once you throw
two or more in the mix but it's well
worth the variety
here are some basic pairing rules to go
by
first pair typefaces with similar
proportions
this means taking into account what we
learned about letter forms from our
first stage
a sans serif type base with a similar x
height
proportions and contrast to a serif type
base can pair well together
you can even utilize super families that
have multiple weights of sands and serif
counterparts
that work great with one another pair
typefaces with complementary
personalities
besides the fact that it's incredibly
helpful one of the things i
really like about hoffler and coast
techniques for combining fonts
is how they talk about their typefaces
personalities or moods
check out the link in the teachers notes
as you pair
typefaces try to classify the mood each
one is conveying
and see if they jive and play well
together
pair typefaces from the same historical
period
jessica hish whose immersive article on
typography is linked in the teacher's
notes
has some great thoughts on this if
you're building a site focused around a
certain time period
then research and find out as much as
you can about typefaces in that
era you might even find some pics of a
storefront or sign with a great typeface
pair for inspiration
pair typefaces from the same designer
type designers
often have a certain style that can be
found throughout each of their faces
the style forms a common bond that holds
the two or more together
this especially works in your favor if
they have a vast array of families to
choose from
lastly explore more try out different
combinations
sometimes you can stumble upon a
typeface pair you wouldn't have imagined
working
it's like kale and frozen bananas you
definitely thought they wouldn't work
together
but oh do they make a tasty smoothie a
great site i love to peruse is called
fontsnews.com
it catalogs different typefaces used in
print
web and all types of media it's great
for inspiration
on different type combinations and pairs
take a few minutes to check it out
all right now let's look at our project
one more time
i've chosen a typeface for the title of
our page whose personality i think pairs
well with the theme of the content
and our serif alegria it's called
pathway gothic 1 and can be found on
google fonts
notice that it doesn't have a bunch of
weights or styles
but that's ok for this specific use
i chose it due to its tall letter forms
and no-nonsense look
i mean if the worlds are at war then
we're not messing around
its tough and classy personality
complements
alegria's elegant and energetic letter
forms
i'll set the title in this font
then i'll adjust our font size to 124
pixels
as i want the title to really stand out
on the page
looks great i really like this typeface
pair
and feel like the body copy keeps our
book vibe intact
while the title gives it an
authoritative look that fits the theme
of the content
it almost feels like a newspaper
declaring a headline
when you get back i'll be waiting for
you in our next video on how to go even
further with typography
we'll talk about how to translate all of
this to different screen sizes
through responsive design discover more
grid systems
explore variable fonts and get into some
finer details of polishing your
typography
[Music]
what might be a joy to read on a desktop
quickly becomes a burden for readers on
smaller screens
white space quickly decreases our large
font sizes overtake the screen and the
content gets cramped
in this video we'll look at how to
remedy those problems through responsive
typography
responsive typography is a subset of
responsive design
focusing solely on the typography as it
responds to different screen sizes
it's extremely important and its details
are often overlooked
creating a pleasant reading experience
for desktop browsers is
great but we also must account for the
other ways someone may be viewing our
site
here are some pointers for how type to
change from mobile versus desktop
first text size generally
from mobile and large body text size
increasing the text size makes it easier
to read on a smaller screen
as for headings they're often too big on
mobile
so it's generally advisable to make them
smaller for mobile
to free up space and make more text fit
comfortably on one or two lines
tighten the leading since the screen is
smaller you'll want to make the best use
of that space
by tightening the space between the
lines since line length is naturally
shorter on the small screen
you can get away with tighter leading
just be careful the leading is ample
enough to be comfortable to read
pay attention to line length on mobile
the number of characters per line should
generally fall within
30 to 40 characters adjust padding as
necessary
you may notice the padding between
paragraphs of text is ample on desktop
with the same amount of space on mobile
creates awkwardly wide gaps
ensure clickable elements such as links
and buttons
are large enough to tap with a fingertip
in the human interface guidelines
apple recommends a minimum target size
of 44 pixels wide
by 44 pixels tall in android's material
design guidelines
48 by 48 dp is recommended
dp stands for device pixels pixels and
dp
are different but similar dp is the
resolution
in relation to the physical size of the
screen
devices have different pixel densities
check out a link in the teacher's notes
to read more
in summary as you practice responsive
typography
adjust the text size leading line length
padding and clickable areas necessary
your hierarchy
might need rearranging so be sure to
translate it clearly at different screen
sizes
lastly your headings are prone to be too
big at small screen sizes
so don't forget to give them some
finesse
i hope that clears up responsive
typography for you
and gives you some simple rules to guide
you along as you practice
remember to trust your gut too on what
looks right
in the next video i'll introduce more
grid systems
earlier you saw how to use a baseline
grid to create rhythm and a design
now we'll cover some other types of
grids
now that you know text is easier to read
when it's in a column
you may find yourself with designs that
have white space
how can you lay out the text and other
content
first up the multi-column grid
multi-column grids
allow you to create hierarchy and
integrate text with photos or graphs
you can define certain zones for photos
and you can allow
content to span multiple columns aim for
an average of 40 to 50 characters per
line
back to our project here's an
alternative way we could lay out the
type in a multi-column grid
to create this click the plus sign to
add another layout grid
you'll want to define the columns so
they match up with the baseline grid
so it's important to see both grids at
once
select columns and set it to 3 columns
for the margin make it 64 pixels so it
spans
2 32 pixel squares
for the gutter make it 32 pixels
this will work best in order to lay out
the type with good measure
then arrange the content to align the
columns while maintaining alignment with
the baseline grid
for the headline you'll need to adjust
the line height and remove
any paragraph spacing if that happened
to be set on the text box
i added a photo of mars to spice up the
white space
as you work on it it helps to hide the
grids to check out how the layout
looks without the red guidelines
second up is the hang line in the hang
line grid
you can divide the page horizontally to
designate a given area of the page
this is called the hang line the area
often contains
images footnotes asides and so on
that complement the main text
lastly the modular grid these were
popular among swiss designers in the
1950s and 1960s
in this style of grid the artboard is
divided into consistent divisions
horizontally and vertically content can
span across sections as you wish
that's it for types of grids keep in
mind when you design for the web
you want to prepare for a range of
screen sizes for instance
a mock-up for a responsive website
design could be in three parts
a desktop design with a three column
grid a tablet design with a two column
grid
and a mobile design with a one column
grid
if you're interested in learning more
check out designers gerschner and
mueller brockman for inspiration
i put some links in the teacher's notes
stay tuned for the next video
where we'll look at the super cool world
of variable fonts
variable fonts are another tool you can
add to your responsive
toolkit a variable font is a single font
file
that behaves like multiple fonts this is
done with axes
that can be adjusted to change aspects
of the font
common axes include weight width
optical size italic and slant
a variable font can have a single axis
or multiple axes
consolidating multiple fonts into one
has a performance advantage
as the file size is smaller and more
efficient
it also allows for more variations and
type styles
dynamically on the screen one use case
for this
is adjusting the font depending on the
reader's device
for example you could heighten the x
height on smaller screens
or you could condense and expand
character widths as the viewport narrows
and widens
let's see some variable fonts in action
4day has the ability to adjust between
serif and sans-serif designs as well as
different weights
devot vore oscillates between a
geometric slab serif
to a decorative and ornamental font
and it can get even more experimental
check out this font called in the pines
which looks like branches growing
i hope that inspired you to check out
more variable fonts
there are so many creative typographers
in the world and i encourage you to be
inspired
by the fonts you can include in your
next project
i'll see you in the next video as we
look into the finer details of
typography
now for the fine details of typography
to really send your designs into a
polished state
1. pay attention to danglies a dangly
is a piece of text that awkwardly
appears on its own line
it can be a single word that wraps into
the next line
or a single line of text that flows to
another column
this imbalance can interrupt reader flow
and impair readability
historically these have been called
orphans and widows
although that's unkind terminology so
i've switched to this inclusive language
coined by design leader melee co
for example let's look at this static
headline that describes a section
on a website the last word wraps to a
new line
on a common desktop screen size
adjust the text box to allow it to flow
in a single line
keep in mind in a design program we have
a lot of control over the layout
but when it becomes a live product that
people use
it's not possible to fine tune it for
every situation
for example we can set these blog
article headlines
to a reasonable text size so that most
headlines fit comfortably on the carts
but in reality headlines of various text
links will be inserted here
and some will appear with a dangly
dynamic content can
only be controlled to a certain extent
in addition
there are a wide range of screen sizes
and device orientations
and it isn't feasible to perfectly plan
the text wrapping for
every scenario so avoid danglings
wherever possible
for common screen sizes but also accept
that you can't completely eradicate them
two use proper punctuation a few common
pitfalls are not using the correct
quotation mark
apostrophe mark and dash the preferred
quotation mark is called a curly quote
this differs from straight quotes which
are used in coding
notice how the open and closed quotes
are different
design programs have an automatic way of
turning quotation marks into curly
quotes
in figma go to the menu in the top left
corner
click preferences and make sure
substitute smart quotes is turned on
otherwise you can manually insert smart
quotes with your keyboard
check out the teacher's notes to see
what keys to press
if you need to interrupt the text do not
use a hyphen
a hyphen is the short line on your
keyboard which is used in hyphenated
words such as
part-time musician then there are n
and m dashes n dashes are a bit longer
than hyphens
and are used to indicate a range of time
or
numbers like one through ten m dashes
are even longer and indicate a break in
thought
for example it's such a beautiful day in
the park
hey is that squirrel wearing a fedora
check out the teacher's nose for the
keystrokes
another feature of open type is
stylistic alternates
when a font has this feature it means
there is more than one option for a
given character
for example a font can have several
different m's to choose from let's look
at an example
railway is a google font with this
feature
go to type details and toggle on and off
the stylistic set 1.
see how the letter forms change such as
the uppercase w
and g i put them next to each other so
you can compare
right you've made it in summary we
analyzed the content
chose a typeface pair to work with put
together a color palette
set up our web fonts and typographic
scale
laid out type with good measure and
rhythm create a typographic hierarchy in
the design
and polished it responsively i hope you
all leave this course with a better
understanding of typography
and know how to execute it well go forth
creating designs with nice type
[Music]
hi i'm hope in this practice session
you'll practice typography here's a
design for a news article
we'll be using this design to practice
typography skills
do you see anything that can be improved
from a typography standpoint
think about how you might improve it
download the project files and you'll
see a couple figma files
open up the file that's labeled before
and
make the improvements if you haven't
used figma yet
you can open a free account when you
have a solution
check out the next video and i'll share
my solution
how did you do were you able to rework
the typography
let me show you what i did first i
noticed the text was set in a single
font
ariel this is a generic font so it isn't
giving the design much character
it's also more dynamic to choose a pair
of fonts that work together
so i knew i wanted a bold display text
for the header
and an easy to read font for the body
text
i landed on patua one for the headline
and meriwether for the body text
which are both available for free via
google fonts
as a reminder to find an appropriate
font for body text
look for a font family that contains a
range of weights
including regular italic and bold
also look for low to moderate stroke
contrast
meaning the text looks balanced and even
with little variation of stroke width
to further optimize for readability look
for large counters
and a tall x height for resources to
find
fonts and font pairings check out the
teachers notes
by the way let's briefly chat about
typescales
when i changed the headline to patua 1 i
increased the text size because i
noticed the design had a low type ratio
the type ratio is the difference between
the largest
and smallest font size so in this case
the largest was 30 pixels and the
smallest was 12 pixels
new sites are designed to grab attention
therefore it's good to aim for a high
type ratio so i made the headline
60 pixels
next i wanted to make the body text even
more readable
by increasing the space between wrapped
lines the 18 pixel body text was
previously set to auto line height
and i increased it to 30 pixels
generally you'll want to set line height
to 130 to 150 percent of text size
although you can play around with it as
it's not a hard rule
i also softened the body text color it
was
all solid black which reads a bit harsh
on the white background
i knocked it down to a dark gray to
retain the contrast while giving it a
softer edge
next i noticed the wide width of the
paragraphs
my eyes are working hard to scan back
and forth over such a wide distance
i shorten the paragraphs to a more
comfortable width
then i rearranged the images and related
stories to fit in the white spaces
created by the text columns
at this point it was looking much better
although i wanted to add more visual
treatment to really spice it up
i added a drop cap which is a classy
old-timey print technique where the
first letter of a paragraph is an
enlarged capital letter
the size typically spans two or three
lines of text
to ease the transition between the drop
cap and the following text
i capitalized the first significant
series of words
it's best to use small caps for this
since they're specifically designed to
be
uppercase letters which scale down to
lowercase height
the meriwether font doesn't support
small caps
so i use regular capitals regular
capitals make the text stand out
a bit more than small caps but
i like the charm this technique is
adding to the design
and is better than trying to do a faux
small caps
the last bit of flourish i added to the
body text was the pull quote
a pull quote is a statement that's
emphasized in an article
this breaks up long values of text
making it more scannable
and entertaining to read finally the
last section i
improved was the intro text the
hierarchy of this text was unclear
making it feel out of balance and
difficult to decipher
i de-emphasize the date and time by
making the text smaller and lightening
the text color
i chose a gray which is lighter than the
primary text color
yet still dark enough to provide enough
contrast
i also moved it above the headline since
i wanted to create a pattern which
allows for a longer title to wrap
i didn't want this text to get in the
way as for the author's name
i tucked it below the subheader to
create a balanced layout and an
appropriate hierarchy
i also softened it by applying the
secondary text color
that's it for the changes by the way i
recommend using
styles and figma by defining text and
color styles
you can define styles once and allow
them to trickle through the elements
across
multiple artboards this makes it
much easier if you decide to switch
fonts or tweak a color later on
instead of changing it for each
individual element
you can adjust the style in one spot for
more info on this
check out the teacher's notes if my
design looked really different from
yours
don't worry remember there are lots of
different solutions to this
and the important thing is to just keep
practicing